bonsoir sabrina bonsoir boris vous venez
très rarement à la télévision je n'ai
jamais vu je crois que c'est la première
fois
jamais on a beaucoup vu votre frère
bruno mais vous très rarement alors
sabrina le 2 novembre 1979
votre meilleur ami vous appelle au
téléphone et vous dis ils ont tué ton
père vous hurlez vous craquer et vous
partez porte de clignancourt où vous
voyez votre père le corps criblé de
balles et broussard heureux exultant
plus tard au quai des orfèvres
vous entendrez brousse à ouvrir le
champagne
il m'a même offert une coupe de
champagne que je lui ai jeté en plein
visage
en fait ils ont laissé mon père trois
heures à terre donc moi je suis arrivé à
ce moment là ils l'ont emmené j'ai suivi
jusqu'au quai des orfèvres j'ai pas pu
le revoir évidemment bon s'arrêter dans
une pièce à côté avec
ces hommes et ils ont
oui champagne alors vous boris le 2
novembre 1979 à 15h15 vous regarder un
dessin animé à la télévision et puis il
subitement le programme s'arrête et puis
d'un coup comme ça sur un écran
fontvergnes et une photo qui apparaît et
une voix qui dit jacques mesrine a été
abattu à ce qu on l'a tous effondrés
vous réalisez que vous ne connaîtrez
jamais votre père et que vous ne serez
comme vous dites jamais s'il vous êtes
exactement donc c'est en regardant la
télévision en étant enfant que j'ai
appris l'allemand de le descellement
père et tout et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là pour moi tout s'est effondré
parce que les questions qu'on peut avoir
par un enfant qui avait jamais connu son
père je sais qu'à ce moment là bas c'est
fini j'aurais jamais les réponses à mes
questions et je sais que j'aurai jamais
un contact avec maintenant vous êtes
heureux finalement de ne pas avoir été à
paris ce jour-là parce que vous l'auriez
vu et vous pensez que j'aurais été
encore plus dur d'après ce que vous en a
dit sabrina
moi je pense que je pense que pour un
enfant c'est pas la meilleure place
devant son père qu en tout cas il ya
trois mois vous avez rallier le combat
de sabrina jusque là pourquoi vous étiez
pas impliqués dans cette recherche je
dirais de la vérité parce que juré la
famille m'a énormément protéger toute
mon enfance ont comme on est trois dans
trois enfants et tout est
ils ont fait leur maximum pour me
protéger de cette paire l'un est comme
ma soeur m'a contacté pour parler de la
procédure qui était en cours j'ai eu les
mêmes amis rallier parce que ça me
permettait d'avoir une identité et des
pouvoirs aussi indirectement me
rapprocher de mon père sabrina vous
voulez porter plainte pour assassinat
dix jours après la fusillade mais tout
ce qu'il n'a contre l'état ça fait donc
24 ans ouais bon jeu nous change de juge
à chaque fois ouais comme par hasard je
suis là seulement parce que monsieur
aimé blanc et là ce soir
ouais et qui me regardent enfin dans les
yeux que ce que tu veux tu tout à
l'heure vous tournez la tête moi je vous
regarde et que vous me dites qu'il ya
pas une sommation dans des choses déjà
nous avons un point commun c'est à dire
que tout à l'heure vous dites que vous
avez jamais connu de votre père vous
avez à 19 ans a perdu notre père moi
j'ai perdu mon père à 9 ans il a été tué
et un des amants je suis pas moins comme
un soufflet qui a perdu son père de
santé français bon je suis pas en train
de dire vous avez perdu votre père
suaire peu importe
malheureusement c'est comme ça je suis
en train de vous dire vous étiez sur les
lieux je suis là pour là ce soir pour
vous me regarder dans les yeux
d'accord et que vous me disiez qu'il n'y
a pas eu de sommation s'il n'y a pas eu
de sommation monsieur aimé blanc il ya
eu assassinat
je suis là que pour la ce soir vous êtes
là parce que vous avez créé un bouquin
moi je n'ai pas écrit un bouquin sur mon
père d'accord parce que le thème mairie
ne m'intéresse pas c'est mon père on n'a
pas ça signer jacques mirin ce jour-là
on assassine et de mon père donc vous
regarder dans les yeux
vous avez écrit un bouquin sur lui donc
ça vous intéresse
sanka vous intéresse vous vous regardez
dans les yeux ce soir et vous me dites
y'a pas eu de sommation s'il n'y a pas
une sommation il ya eu assassinat
je peux pas vous dire qu'apple de
sommation evolis nous dit maintenant je
peux pas vous dire puisque je n'étais
pas là monsieur brou sort n'était pas là
il est personnel
les inspecteurs bon peut-être ont-ils
fait des sommations peut-être ce qui
nous est faite puisque depuis vingt
trois ans à lui 1 et a certainement de
sérieux doutes qui n'a de zepa fait mais
c'est aux magistrats instructeurs a
déclaré la vérité moi je peux pas vous
dire
il passa dans notre livre qu'est ce que
je dis dans mon vient pas une sommation
vous savez très bien qu'il existe que
bruce a vu des sommations puisqu'il
était avec vous la même chose à la halle
à la volaille a réagi immédiatement
2 il a été placé vous avez attendu 24
ans tout d'un coup pour dire tout d'un
coup y'a peut-être pas eu sommation moi
ça fait 24 ans que je me bats vous avez
attendu 24 ans vous ah mais attendez je
sais pas j'ai pas attendu 24 ans j'ai
travaillé mais je dois personnel je
raconte une histoire que j'ai vécu
professionnellement et je le début de
cette histoire explique peut-être la fin
voici un jeu ciel et blanc est ce que
vous comprenez ce que sabrina vous dis
là ce soir
ça veut dire que si dans les yeux vous
lui dites qu a pas eu de sommation pour
elle pour lui c'est une réhabilitation
pour leur père pourquoi l'importance que
ça peut pas dire si j'avais 24 ans
qu'ils essayent je n'étais pas vrai ce
porteur ne peut pas dire je n'étais pas
mais les inspecteurs
donc je ne peux pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
eu de sommation en revanche ce que je
peux dire c'est qu'il ya des doutes sur
ce fait qu'ils aient pas eu de sommation
ya de sérieux doutes que vous aviez à
cette époque je pensais quand même très
importante
vous le savez s'il ya une sommation ou
pas sommation mais je t'ai pas que je
commandais pas bien ce côté là si c'est
moi qui avais commandé dispositif je
vous dirai pas fait de sommations
d'ailleurs je dis dans mon fils dans mon
livre que peut-être je lui ai donné
ordre aux inspecteurs de tirer les
premiers
mais comme c'est pas moi qui commandait
je ne peux pas vous dire s'il ya eu des
sommations pas parce que dès que le taux
d'intervention a été donnée par bruce à
la radio c'est tout il ya eu des rafales
terminée enfin de toute façon c'est
quand même un assassinat monsieur aimé
blanc on tire pas 19 balles dans les
corps d'un homme une balle dans la tempe
à bout portant
je pense que c'est quand même un
assassinat c'est de l'abattage là je
pense que c'était mal fait malmener
mais la difficulté c'est qu'il est comme
j'expliquais y en avait peut-être pas
d'autres occasions il y avait une
pression du politique
ce concert a eu des occasions dans sa
vie de l'arrêter à que champagne encore
une fois et ray champagne six mois et
coûté je n'avais pas de haine pour
autant père je connaissais pas j'ai
jamais vu sinon à la fin quand vous avez
pas vu de choses à tous pensent que
mesrine a été exécuté par par la police
parce qu'il y avait des ordres des
politiques parce qu'il était devenu très
gênant donc cantonné dans un état de
droit
même les assassins ce qui était le cas
de mesrine ont droit à le respect de
l'état de droit c'est à dire à des
sommations lorsqu'il y à un guet-apens
qui est fait par les services de police
c'est l'état de droit qu'il aurait levé
la main qu'ils se sont procurées ben je
sais pas ce qu'il aurait fait peut-être
qu'il aurait pris sa coréen allait
peut-être qu'il aurait été qu'il aurait
été tué lors d'une altercation avec la
police mais selon la meilleure manière
pour l'état de droit de s'y faire
respecter c'est de respecter y compris
ceux qui se met en dehors de ces règles
donc mesrine s'était mis en dehors des
règles de l'état de droit
il a tué des gens mais en même temps je
pense que ce qui s'est passé avec
mesrine j'étais journaliste à l'époque
pour nous tous c'était évident qu'il
s'agissait d'une exécution
c'est vrai que ce sera très difficile
pour les enfants de jacques mesrine
d'obtenir gain de cause parce qu'on sait
très bien que dans ces circonstances là
l'état ne reconnaît jamais sa faute bien
donc lucien aimé-blanc vous ne pouvez
pas dire à sabrina mesrine en la
regardant dans les yeux il n'y a pas une
sommation
je peux pas je n'étais pas sur place je
peux pas me brusa en anglais
après que ça arrivera ce qui n'est pas
très reluisant sommation ce sens pour le
commissaire broussard est invité sur ce
plateau la semaine prochaine s'il veut
répondre à ce qui a été dit à son sujet
ce soir voilà merci d'être venu ici pour
être sûrs de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus